هجوم جديد يستهدف مخيم الركبان على الحدود
السوريه الاردنيه الحصيله عشرات المصابين
ليس الهجوم الاول الذي يهز ثانيه اكبر
مخيمات السوريين الهاربين من المعارك بعد
مخيم الزعتري لكنه على ما يبدو يختلف عن
سابقيه حيث اقتصرت خسائره على المدنيين
دون وجود اهداف امنيه او عسكريه واضحه مما
يثير العديد من التساؤلات عن الهدف منه
والجهه التي تقف وراءه والجهه المستهدفه
حقا في المنطقه التي توصف بالحرام على
الحدود الاردنيه السوريه تفجير بسياره
مفخخه يضرب مخيم ركبان للاجئين السوريين
خلف التفجير قتلى وعشرات الجرحى بينهم
اطفال ونساء ضربه موجعه جديده على التراب
الاردني وليست الاولى في المخيم احداث
امنيه عده شهدتها البلاد التي تقع على
حدودها الشماليه والشرقيه اكثر البؤر
اشتعالا سوريا والعراق فعلى الرغم من
التدابير الامنيه المشدده في المخيم بعد
حوادث امنيه سابقه استطاع المنفذ وضع
سياره ملغمه في سوق المخيم المكتظ الذي
يربو قاطنوه على 100000 لم تعلن اي جهه
بعد تبني العمليه لكن يعتقد على نطاق واسع
ان تنظيم الدوله يقف وراءها فقد تبنى
عمليات سابقه على التراب الاردني تدرك
عمان منذ وقت مبكر انها مقصد للتنظيمات
المسلحه ولا سما في المناطق الصحراويه
التي تعتبر خاصرتها الرخوه فمنها تتخذ
تنظيمات منطلقا لعملياتها ورغم تعزيز
الاردن اجراءات الرقابه والانتشار العسكري
المكثف على امتداد حدوده مع العراق وسوريا
فانه ما زال يعاني من طول تلك الحدود
وصعوبه ضبطها واحكام السيطره عليها ويزيد
الوضع تعقيدا شبه انهيار الدوله في سوريا
اذ تمتد الحدود معها لقراه 400 م ما حدا
بالاردن الى الاعتماد على مجموعات سوريه
معارضه تعرف باسم جيش العشائر واخرى
عراقيه لسد الفجوات الامنيه
ومجابهته الركبان الجديد يسلط الضوء مره
اخرى على الاوضاع المترديه التي يعيشها
سكان هذا المخيم لا سما بعد اعلان الاردن
حدوده الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه منطقه
عسكريه مغلقه منذ يونيو حزيران الماضي كما
يفتح الباب من جانب اخر على تساؤلات حول
قدره الاردن على صد التنظيمات المسلحه
المتسلله عبر الحدود الملتهبه وابعاد شبح
العمليات الامنيه عن اراضيه في ظل ما يبدو
محاولات من تلك التنظيمات للعوده الى
مربعها الاول في المناطق الص الصحراويه
قبل اعلان ما يسمى دوله الخلافه خصوصا بعد
الضربات التي تتلقاها وما تواجهه من ضغوط
دوليه مستمره وينضم الينا من عمان الخبير
في شؤون الجماعات الاسلاميه محمد ابو رمان
وكذلك من باريس المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجي السوري عبد الناصر العايد
سيد عبد الناصر تفجير جديد داخل مخيم
الركبان من هو المستفيد ومن هو المستهدف
هذه المره
يعني البصمات تشير الى تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه لكن في مناخ يعني امنن الصراع
حاليا وتعدد وتشعب وتشابك الصراعات يمكن
ان يكون لاطراف اخرى مصلحه في في هذه
العمليه او تكون ضالع بها لا ندري عنها
شيئا خصوصا انه العمليه يعني من حيث
المبدا شبه يعني فشلت ليست لم تحقق لم تصب
هدف محددا
اي التفجير بوسط مدنيين دون دون اي اي
تحديد حتى يعني يبدو انه التفجير بمدخل
المخيم او على اطرافه لم يعني اوقع عدد
كبير من الضحايا لكن ليس
بضخامه الضحايا لو كان يعني توغل في داخل
المخيم وفي داخل السوق الذي ضربه لذلك
يعني مبدئيا يعني كما قلت البصمات هي
بصمات
تنظيم داعش ويمكننا التساؤل هنا مع السيد
محمد ابو ربمان هل المستهدف من هذه
العمليه داخل مخيم الركبان هو المخيم نفسه
ام القوات الاردنيه والحكومه
الاردنيه مساء الخير اولا لا اعتقد انه
المستهدف من قبل اذا اذا كان الذي قام
بهذه العمليه هو بالفعل ما يسمى تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه لا اظن ان مستهدف هم
السكان لا يوجد مصلحه للتنظيم في استهداف
سكان المخيم وانا يعني ارتكز بشكل كبير
على الكلمه التي ذكرها الضيف من باريس
بانه العمليه فشلت وبالتالي يصعب في ضوء
هذه الحيثيات معرفه من المستهدف وان كان
اذا كان التنظيم ورائها فعلى الاغلب نحن
امام ايه احتمالين رئيسيين الاحتمال الاول
ان يكون ان هذه العمليه كانت في طور
الاعداد لاستهداف اخر ل النقطه الحدوديه
الاردنيه مع مخيم الركبان والاحتمال
الثاني هو ان يكون بعض فصائل الجبهه
الجنوبيه المتحالفه مع الاردن التي عهد
اليها بترتيبات امنيه داخل المخيم بعد
الهجوم السابق ان تكون هي المستهدفه او ما
يسمى جيش سوريا الجديد او جيش عشائر سوريا
ربما يعني الفصائل المتحالفه مع الاردن
اذا كان التنظيم وعلى الاغلب بتقديري انه
التنظيم هو الذي يقف وراء هذه العمليه
لكنها لم تنجح وبالتالي كانت الخسائر
للاسف الشديد خسائر مدنيه وبشريه في
المخيم وهذا ما اكدته وكالت الانباء
الاردنيه حيث نفت وجود استهداف اي اردني
داخل المخيمات وذلك نقلا عن مصدر عسكري
بالتالي متابعه لما كنت تقول سيد محمد ابو
رمان هل ينطبق تنطبق ملامح هجوم يونيو
الماضي على ما حصل
اليوم انا بعتقد انه يعني ممكن احتمال
كبير وهذا من المفترض انه السلطات
الاردنيه تضعه في حسابها بانه يكون بالفعل
هنالك نوايا للتنظيم للقيام بعمليات اخرى
لكن ما هو اهم من هذا وذلك بتقديري هو انه
هذه المنطقه تحديدا المنطقه الشماليه
والشماليه الشرقيه اصبحت اليوم في منظور
صانع القرار في عمان هي اهم التحديات
العسكريه والامنيه بالنسبه للاردن بمعنى
انه عمليات انزياح
للخطر الذي يمثله ما يسمى تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه اصبحت في هذه المنطقه تحديدا
وبالتحديد خلال معركه الموصل وما بعده
هنالك قراءات بانه هنالك عناصر عديده بدات
تتوجه الى هذه المنطقه الى دير الزور الى
ريف دير الزور الى ريف حمص وبالتالي
التنظيم يسعى الى اقامه او الى تعزيز
وجوده في هذه المنطقه وهنالك الخطر اصبح
اكثر اقترابا للاردن في هذه المنطقه
الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه المحاذيه للحد
والركبان واعتقد انه في جلسات سابقه يعني
كان الاردنيون او المسؤولون الارد
يتحدثون بوضوح عن انه هذه المنطقه تحولت
بالفعل الى مصدر التهديد رقم واحد بالنسبه
للاردن على المناطق الحدوديه سيد عبد
الناصر عايد هل ترى ايضا ان التنظيم
بالفعل بدا يلجا الى المناطق الجنوبيه بعد
التضييق عليه في الموصل وفي الرقه
تحديدا يعني هو
التنظيم تنظيم يتميز بالمرونه وخف الحركه
ويعني له تاريخ طويل في التخفي والعمل
والنشاط في المناطق الصحراويه لا نستطيع
ان نقول انه بدا يعني يفكر في هذه المناطق
ويمتد اليها لكن كما يعني قال الضيف وكما
قال الكثير من المراقبون انه يعني يبدو
انه بدات تصبح هذه المنطقه منطقه شمال
الاردن وجنوب سوريا ضمن دائره الطموحات
والاستهداف المستقبلي يعني ضمن الخطط
الاستراتيجيه للتنظيم و يعني يكثف عمله
هناك يعني لم يتركها هذه المنطقه هذا
المخيم لوحده تعرض لثلاث تفجيرات ولديه
نشاطات في في المنطقه
اي بالتاكيد يعني كل منطقه لها ميزاتها
ولها يعني طرق الاستفاده منها وهو يحاول
ان ستفيد من من كافه المناطق يعني لا سي ع
الناصر الد اسمح لي يعني منطقه صحراويه
مكشوفه جدا واعره وخاليه من طرق الامداد
اختيارها هل يتسق مع مع استراتيجيه
التنظيم المعتاده في اختياره مع قله
بعنايه
اي كما قلت لكل منطقه لديها يعني ما يمكن
ان يتم استثماره
فيها التنظيم يتبع اسلوب حرب العصابات
اللي بيستفيد من كل الامكانيات الطبيعيه
والبيئيه الموجوده والبشريه
وغيرها بهذه المنطقه يعني صحيح هي منطقه
مو ما فيها كثافه عمرانيه ما فيها تعقيد
تضاريس ما فيها تعقيد بالطوب
رافيا وبالتالي يعني ما ممكن الاستفاده
منها كثيرا بحرب العصابات لكنها تحتوي
ايضا بعض امكانيه الاختباء والتخفي هناك
اوديه سحيقه هناك مغاور هناك بعض الجبال
ايضا هي تشكل طرق ربط ويعني مواصلات
يستثمرها
بنشاطاته كل هذه العوامل يمكن ان ان تكون
يعني ذات فائده له خصوصا انه معاقله
الرئيسيه مثل ما حكيتي اصبحت مستهدفه كلها
محاصره ومراقبه بدقه وهي تكون مليئه يعني
فيها كثافات سكانيه هذه الكثافات السكانيه
اصبحت مصدر خطر له ربما كان الذهاب الى
مناطق فارغه يعني افضل له من من من بعض
النواحي سيد محمد ابو رمان الاردن كيف له
ان يوفق بين مسالتين او هاجس انساني يتعلق
بمطالبه منظمات دوليه وانسانيه بانقاذ
وتحسين ظروف ال النازحين السور داخل مخيم
الركبان وبين هاجس امني يقول ان تنظيم
الدوله بالفعل بحسب التجارب والاحداث
يتربص
بالاردن دعيني يعني ادمج ما بين هذا
السؤال والسؤال السابق لانهم انا بعتقد
مترابطين بشكل مهم جدا واعتقد انه من
المهم انه صانع القرار في الاردن ينتبه
الى هذه القضيه صحيح انه هذه المنطقه ربما
تكون مكشوفه عسكريا وامنيا لكن التنظيم
يعتمد على ما يسمى تنظيف دير الزور من
الجيش السوري وبالتالي ضمان محافظه دير
الزور والامتداد ثم الى هذه المناطق خطوره
الركبان بتقديري هي الكثافه السكانيه في
مخيم الركبان في ظل الظروف الامنيه
والانسانيه القهريه في هذا المخيم اخشى ما
اخشاه ان ان يحاول التنظيم القيام بعمليات
التجنيد والتغلغل
والتواري في هذه المنطقه الحساسه وبالتالي
هنا تصبح المعادله اعقد بكثير مما
بمعنى ان الاردن اخذ احتياطات عسكريه اعلن
انها منطقه عسكريه مغلقه بالرغم من انه
يحاول استئناف او الاستمرار في الدوري
الانساني لكن في الحدود الدنيا مقارنه
بالمرحله السابقه بعد تفجير الركبان
السابق لكن في الوقت نفسه ترك هذه المنطقه
بهذه الظروف الانسانيه القهريه هذه فرصه
هامه لتنظيم داعش ليتغلغل فيها وبالتالي
يسيطر على قطاعات من السكان ويقوم بملء
الفراغ في هذا المخيم وفي هذه المنطقه
هنالك قراءات امنيه لدى الاردن بانه
بالفعل التنظيم لديه حضور في مخيم الركبان
فما بالك اذا كان هنالك التعامل مع هذه
المنطقه فقط من المعيار العسكري والامني
اعتقد انه الخطوره على المدى البعيد
ستزداد ولن تقل هذا الدور لا يقف بصراحه
على الاردن وحده بمعنى ان هنالك عبء كبير
على المنظمات الانسانيه على المجتمع
الدولي على دول الجوار حتى تستطيع بناء
معادله صحيه في التعامل مع هذا المخيم
الذي اص عدده سكانه تقريبا 100000 وهنالك
بالقرب منه مخيم الحدت وهنالك حديث عن انه
عدد سكانه 3 ال نسبه كبيره من هؤلاء من
الاطفال والنساء وبالتالي امكانيه التجنيد
والاستثمار في الظروف الانسانيه القهريه
امكانيه كبيره من قبل التنظيم سيد عبد
الناصر العايد باختصار لو سمحت التحالف
والاردن عضو فيه برايك وحسب متابعتك هل
يمكن ان يغير الاستراتيجيه القتاليه تجاه
التنظيم وهو يراه حسب المعطيات يتجه جنوبا
يعني لابد من تغيير الاستراتيجيات وضيفك
من الاردن تكلم عن يعني معلومات عن صانع
القرار بالاردن انه يعني منتبه لهي
المساله لابد من يعني تعزيز الامن في في
هذه المناطق هذه المنطقه وحولها ولكن يجب
الانتباه ان لا يكون هذا الامر على حساب
السكان اللي عددهم كبير جدا بين 75 ل
100000 هؤلاء يعيشون في المخيم الاكثر
بؤسا بالنسبه لمخيمات النزوح السوري
وبالتالي امكانيه التجنيد عاليه جدا بينهم
واي سياسه ت يعني تتجه الى التضييق عليهم
هي سياسه ستزيد من فرص داعش في يعني تنفيذ
طموحاته ايه زيا زياده الاعتماد على
الفصائل السوريه ال يعني الثوريه الموجوده
بالمنطقه لحمايه المنطقه ودفع الخطر بعيدا
هذا ايضا يعني ايه تصرف رئيسي واساسي في
في في هذا الاطار سيد سيد محمد ابو رمان
اختم معك ما حصل اليوم في مخيم الركبان هل
سيسلط الضوء من جديد على معاناه السكان في
الداخل ام على خطر تنظيم
الدوله على الاثنين معا انا بتقديري ولا
ولا يجوز ان نفصل بينهما بل لابد من الربط
بينهما لانه تنظيم الدوله لم ياتي من فراغ
ولم يهبط من المريخ وبالتالي علينا انه ان
لا نفصل ما بين الجانب العسكري والامني
والجانب الانساني وهذا اعتقد هذه الرساله
المهمه والدرس المستفاد الاكبر مما حدث
اليوم في الركبان بالاضافه الى ما قاله
الضيف مندك الاخ عبد الناصر من باريس في
هناك نقطه مهمه الاردن اعتمد على نظريه
الوسادات يعني على الجيش الحر وعلى
الفصائل الجبهه الجنوبيه وبالفعل بعد
تفجير الركبان الاخير عزز الاردن وجود هذه
الفصائل في الركبان لكن من الواضح انه هذه
الفصائل تتعرض هي الاخرى لضغوط شديده وانا
اخ ما اخشاه فعلا في المرحله القادمه اذا
ما توجه الجيش النظام السوري باتجاه درعا
وباتجاه المناطق الجنوبيه ان تزداد الضغوط
على هذه الفص ويؤدي الامر ونشهد عمليه
عكسيه بمعنى انهيار هذه الفصائل سيستفيد
ايضا منه تنظيم داعش في المرحله القادمه
اذا هي معادله مركبه معادله معقده لا يجوز
الاتكاء على جانب ونسيان الجوانب الاخرى
اشكرك جزيلا محمد ابو رمان الخبيره في
شؤون الجماعات الاسلاميه كنت ضيفنا من
عمان والشكر موصول ايضا لعبد الناصر
العايد المحلل العسكري والاستراتيجي سوري
كنت معنا من باريس اشكركما ضيفين الكريمين
بهذا نص الى نهايه الحصاد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء